العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن
سلمان وامير قطر الشيخ تميم بن
افريقيا بريت ماغورك. نيران كانت
تستعد لشن هجوم على السعودية.
يواجه خطر الابعاد عن الكأس بسبب
جواز مزور لاحد لاعبيه يحمل
العالم لصحفي اسرائيلي انت وقح.
شكرا لكل شخص وصل لهذه الدقيقة.
والجرحى لتصرح ايضا انها دمرت
تسعة وثمانين هدفا بما في ذلك
لتسهيل دخول السويد وفنلندا الى
الناتو? الاحداث والتطورات.
الى الاعلام العربي عن وجود
تنسيق بين واشنطن وانقرة بشأن
هامش كأس العالم فيفا قطر الفين
واثنين وعشرين في اول لقاء يجمع
للمنطقة. تداول نشطاء على مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي صورة لولي
المشروع. ولكن هنا تركيا لا تنسى
ايضا ان تنفس عن غضبها لتنتقم من
جنسية اخرى. المغني الكولومبي
مالوما المشارك في اغنية كأس
بين السعودية والولايات المتحدة.
وهو امر متواصل. واكد ان
حمد في الدوحة يليها مصافحة حارة
بين اردوغان والسيسي في قطر على
ملاجئ ومستودعات ذخيرة للمسلحين
الاكراد لتسرب بعد ذلك تقارير
اتصال مع بكين من جهته يتوقع
الرئيس الصيني ان يعمل اكبر
ام ان هناك مآرب اخرى. صراخ
صواريخ كيم لا يتوقف. لا تتوقف
مناورة عسكرية اعتيادية لسلاحي
بحرية اليابان والولايات المتحدة
تتعرض لها بلاده. ياتي ذلك بعد
ان اعلنت كوريا الجنوبية ان
وزارة الدفاع شن عملية عسكرية
جديدة ضد المواقع الكردية شمالي
وثمانية عشر في مؤشر الى انفراج
في العلاقات الثنائية كما يبدو
ومن المرجح ان هذا الهجوم لم
يحدث بسبب التعاون الامني الوثيق
الاقتصادية الامريكية على العالم
بحلول عام الفين واربعين. حينها
بينهما. وبعد فوز الاكوادور على
قطر في افتتاح كأس العالم الفين
ثمارها للاتراك. فها هي انقرة
تتوقع بدء العمل في تنفيذ مشروع
اما في كييف فان نائب وزير
الدفاع الاوكراني يقول القوات
في وذلك بهدف اختبار جاهزية تلك
الدول على وقوع هجمات مسلحة
واثنين وعشرين اشارت صحيفة ديلي
ميل البريطانية ان الاكوادور
للولايات المتحدة. والامريكان
يعتقدون انه الهدوء الذي يسبق
وكالة فرانس بريس عن منسق مجلس
الامن القومي للشرق الاوسط وشمال
الكورية توترا. وكالة الانباء
الكورية نقلت عن الزعيم الكوري
امريكا تهدد بيد لتفاوض باخرى
ابعد ايام من لقاء شي جين بينغ
هذه المرة? تركيا تنفس عن غضبها.
سياسة مسك العصا من المنتصف تؤتي
مجموعة السبع وتطالب مجلس الامن
باتخاذ اجراءات بعد اطلاق كوريا
عمليات تفجير اسطنبول ولكن هذه
المرة برعاية امريكية. حيث اعلنت
والبحري في الشرق الاوسط في رد
على تهديدات ايران المستمرة
الولايات المتحدة تعمل على بناء
بنية تحتية متكاملة للدفاع الجوي
الشمالي قوله انه سيستخدم اسلحة
نووية للرد على التهديدات التي
العملية التركية في سوريا
والعراق يكون كسب ود اردوغان
تطوير اسلحته الفرد صوتية والهدف
مواكبة الصين وروسيا. بينما هنا
سوريا والعراق تحت اسم مخلب
السيف ما اسفر عن عشرات القتلى
الشمالية لذلك الصاروخ الجديد
والمرعب. لتعلن المملكة المتحدة
الجميع بانتظار حفلة استقبال كيم
للانجليز فماذا ستقدم لهم يا كيم
اصحاب العيون الضيقة لا يلعبون.
الهدوء الصيني ليس علامة خير
المحتملين لضمان امن الطاقة في
اوروبا وتوازن السوق من خلال هذا
وبايدن ايا كاميلا هاريس تلتقي
الرئيس الصيني على هامش قمة ابك
مشاركة سفينة من البحرية
البريطانية للمرة الاولى في
ومستقرة. فهل تكون هذه التصريحات
ابرة مخدرة للامريكان حتى تاخذ
مركز الذي اقترحه بوتين اعتبارا
من بداية العام المقبل. وفي هذا
تسمح لبكين بملئ الفراغات في
البحار والمحيطات حيث نقلت سي ان
عن اطلاق الصواريخ وهي الوجبة
اليومية والمفضلة لزعيمها كما
بكين لقمتها الكبيرة بغزو من
يدري لتعلن بعدها واشنطن ان وزير
التفاهم والاخطاء في الحكم
لتعزيز عودة علاقات سليمة
يبدو ويوما بعد يوم تزداد
الاوضاع العسكرية في شبه الجزيرة
خارجيتها انتوني بلينكن سيزور
الصين مطلع العام الفين وثلاثة
يسعى للصدام مع روسيا ولا يشكل
تهديدا لها. وشدد اوستن على ان
جارتها اطلقت ما يبدو انه صاروخ
بالستي عابر للقارات لتخرج
وعشرين وستكون هذه اول زيارة
لمسؤول امريكي كبير منذ الفين
اقتصادين في العالم الصيني
والامريكي على خفض حالات سوء
العاصمة الاوكرانية كييف هناك
كداسوناك ان بريطانيا ستواصل
اكد هاريس خلال لقائه القصير مع
شيه باهمية الابقاء على قنوات
الاطار تجري انقرة سلسلة من
المفاوضات مع موردي الغاز
ومن حرب اصوات التهديدات الى
اصوات الرصاص والابادات
جنديا في قصف بعيد بالمدفعية.
بينما حذر مستشار رئيس شركة روس
الاوكراني وهو ما تحذر منه
الوكالة الدولية للطاقة الذرية.
الاوكرانية. حيث اتهمت كييف
روسيا بتنفيذ هجوم مكثف على محور
العاصفة. هنا وزير الدفاع
الامريكي لويد استون واشنطن لن
اتوم ريناد من خطر حدوث تلوث
نووي في محطة بسبب القصف
لاعادة اعمار اوكرانيا. فكيف
سترد روسيا على سوناك يا ترى?
الدعم العسكري لاوكرانيا مضيفا
نعمل جاهدين على الدعم المالي
لموجة تعبئة ثانية على الرغم من
تصريح بوتين في الحادي والثلاثين
من اكتوبر بان التعبئة الرسمية
التي اعلن عنها الشهر السابق قد
باخمود في دونيتسك. وقالت
اوكرانيا انها قتلت حوالي ستين
ان عن مسؤول عسكري امريكي ان
البنتاجون يزيد وتيرة اختبار
انتهت وفقا لموقع نيوز ويك
الامريكي. ليعلنها الناتو صراحة
على لسان وزير الدفاع الامريكي
اوستن ان الناتو حلف دفاعي ولا
البريطاني تفقد مدفعية روسية
محطمة خلال جولة للزعيمين في
الناتو لكن لا يبالي بالتصريحات
الغربي ليمضي بصحبة رئيس الوزراء
لن ينجر الى الحرب في اوكرانيا
حاليا فهل فهمت كييف رسالة
امريكية فحسب مركز الابحاث
الامريكية فان الكرملين يستعد
الاوكرانية قد تعود الى شبه
جزيرة القرن بنهاية ديسمبر
ستتم اعادة تقسيم العالم
اقتصاديا لانه سيصبح الاقطاب.
وسبعمائة صاروخ منذ بداية الحرب
واحرقت مئات المدن والبلدات.
لا يحركون شيئا من مكانه عبثا.
ليحذر وزير الدفاع الامريكي لويد
التي تخسر. اذا فاوكرانيا تعلنها
لا للتفاوض. ليصرح كبير مساعدي
خطر انتشار الاسلحة النووية في
حال انتصار روسيا بحربها ضد
الاربع التي ضمتها روسيا مؤخرا
اضافة لشبه جزيرة القرم. بينما
البحر الاسود. فهل حان وقت الحرب
من البحر ايها الروسيون فالروس
لوكالة انباء الاوكرانية ليأتي
هنا الرد الروسي ولكن بدراسات
اوكرانيا حدود عام واحد وتسعين
الحدود التي تشمل المقاطعة
برونيوسيس السويسري للابحاث
والاستشارات توقع انتهاء الهيمنة
تدور رحاها منذ فترة طويلة
والهدف اعادة تشكيل العالم
وستنتهي الحرب باكملها مع روسيا
بحلول الربيع القادم. وذلك وفقا
اقتصاديا وسياسيا بما يتفق مع
موازين القوى العالمية. فمعهد
الرئيس الاوكراني زلينيسكي
اندريا ماك ان السلام مع روسيا
لن يكون ممكن الا عندما يتم
تدمير الجيش الروسي وتستعيد
ليرى هنا الكثير من ان الحرب
الروسية الاوكرانية ستار لمعركة
على كييب للتفاوض. يرد ميخائيل
مستشار الرئيس الاوكراني هذا
الاخيرة هنا? الامم المتحدة
تطالب كييف بالتحقيق في فيديو
قبل ان تسحب قواتها من اراضينا.
فاستعادة الارض مقابل السلام.
اعدام اسرى حرب الروس. وبينما
ياتي الضغط الغربي بقيادة واشنطن
لن تتنازل عن شبر من اراضيها.
اسمعتم? فهل هي نشوة الانتصارات
اوستن ان روسيا والصين تسعيان
الى عالم تحكمه القوة مشيرا الى
زلانسكي يستبعد الدخول في هدنة
قصيرة مع روسيا ويقول اوكرانيا
اوكرانيا زلانسكي يعود مجددا
ليصرح روسيا استخدمت اربعة الاف
وامريكا تعلن عن حماية السعودية
من اي هجوم محتمل فلم كل هذا
الجيش الاوكراني قال انه رصد
تحركات سبع سفن روسية معادية في
وليس في كييف. الرد من الرئاسة
الاوكرانية. لا محادثات مع روسيا
التملق. بوتين يفاوض زيلانسكي.
موسكو اخذت قطعة من الجاتوه
وامير قطر وبين السيسي وحفيد
عثمان. فهل حان وقت التصالح
الاوكراني ايضا. وها هو مجلس
الدوم الروسي يعلن انه لم يغلق
يعني ان الدولة التي تستعيد
اراضيها يجب ان تستسلم للدولة
باب المفاوضات مع اوكرانيا مضيفا
ان قرار اوكرانيا يتخذ في واشنطن
من وسط كييف والنيتو يطالب
بالهدوء واوكرانيا تعلن موعد
نهاية الحرب. وبين اصحاب العيون
الضيقة والامريكان تزداد
اللقاءات الرومانسية الذي يدور
فيها الوضع في شبه الجزيرة
الكورية يزداد سوءا وكيم يصرخ هل
من مزيد تركيا تنفس عن غضبها
الاوكراني. واليوم ها هي تقبل
بالتفاوض لكن على ما في ايدي
ويجري اتفاقا مع واشنطن. واهازيج
كأس العالم تجمع بين ابن سلمان
اوكرانيا. فما الذي يجري ورئيس
الوزراء البريطاني يعلن التحدي
لتعلن انتقامها بينما اردوغان
يبدأ بتنفيذ خطة الرئيس الروسي
بوتين ولكن على طريقته الخاصة.
بينما تحوم سبع سفن روسية حول
مقابل الارض. اسمعت يا بوتين?
نعم. هكذا تحدث زيلينسكي ليرد
ستجدون جميع مصادر الاخبار في
اول تعليق.